Hey! Nice pants!
Excuse me?
I said nice pants.
You can't see my pants, can you?
Of course I can.
How can you see my pants?
They're on your legs!
You haven't been to America recently, have you?
Well, I have actually.
I've just got back from LA.
That's Los Angeles, by the way.
I know.
Yeah, I picked up some of the American words and now I forget which ones to use!
So confusing!
Well, we call these trousers in Britain.
Of course we do.
You know, there are so many things though,...
...it's like a completely different language sometimes.
Really?
Yeah!
Would you like a crisp?
Crisps? In the States, they're chips!
Oh. So, if I want to order our chips in America, what do I ask for?
French fries!
I see.
And you know what that is, don't you?
A fizzy drink.
That's a soda!
You know the lift over there?
Yeah?
That's an elevator.
Oh, really?
You know, in the States, you don't go to watch a film.
You watch a movie!
Exactly! And you don't walk on the pavement.
You walk on the sidewalk!
You got it!
I've watched a lot of films. Oops, movies.